speaker will make a statement of the
house from the situation in turkey and
Syria
on Monday morning at 1 17 a.m UK time a
major earthquake
struck South Eastern Turkey and
Northwestern Syria measuring 7.8 on the
Richter state scale the quake's impact
was felt hundreds of miles away in
Lebanon Cyprus Greece and Israel just
nine hours later at 10 24 London time a
second major earthquake struck the same
region with a magnitude of 7.5 on the
Richter scale first Tremor centered on
the Turkish city of gazian tap some 150
miles from the Turkish Syrian border the
epicenter of the second Quake was
approximately 80 miles further north Mr
Speaker earthquakes of this severity
have not been seen in this region in
this region for 80 years
the effects of these two earthquakes
have been devastating at least
at least
2291 deaths have already been confirmed
by the Turkish authorities and at least
834 have been reported injured
these numbers I regret to inform the
house are highly likely to rise
significantly
I know the house will join me today in
offering arts and seek condolences to
the people of turkey and Syria
across the region inhabited by more than
12 million people more than 6 000
buildings have collapsed electricity and
gas infrastructure has been severely
damaged
many of the 3.5 million Syrian refugees
hosted by turkey reside in the affected
provinces turkey's outstanding disaster
relief response capability has been
severely tested by the sheer scale of
this catastrophe the Turkish government
has declared a state of emergency and
they are requesting International
assistance on a scale that matches the
enormity of the situation that they are
facing turkey will lead the disaster
relief response in the areas of Syria
where it has a presence
as of this morning we know that three
British Nationals are missing and the
foreign office is crisis response Hub is
working to support the at least 35
British Nationals who have been directly
affected by these earthquakes we assess
that the likelihood of large-scale
British casualties remains low the
Turkish government has contacted his
Majesty's government to request support
and we're working closely with our
Turkish allies to provide them with the
help that they need a swiftly and as
effectively as possible I've been in
direct contact with my Turkish
counterpart and I plan to speak to the
un's under Secretary General for
humanitarian Affairs and emergency
relief coordination this afternoon to
discuss future steps I can tell the
house that our 77 strong Urban search
and rescue team with four dogs and
state-of-the-art equipment is due to
arrive at gazian tap later today I've
also authorized the deployment of a UK
emergency medical assessment team
in Syria the UK is in contact with our
partners on the ground to establish
their needs and to decide how best to
help
the conflict stability and Security fund
will provide an uplift to the opposition
syrians uh Syrian Civil Defense commonly
known as the white helmets to support
their emergency response operations
across North West Syria we're also
providing support to Syria through the
International Medical Corps and through
save the children and of course through
the United Nations agencies Mr Speaker
we will continue to stand by the people
of turkey and Syria we will deliver Aid
to those in need wherever they are and
we will do so and as we do so
we will work with our allies and
partners around the world to ensure the
most effective humanitarian response I
undertake to keep the house updated on
the situation on turkey and Syria as it
evolves and I commend the statement to
the house shuttle foreign secretary
David Lammy
occurred the massive earthquakes that
struck Southern turkey and Northern
Syria on Monday have caused utter
devastation
more than 5 000 people are likely killed
tens of thousands injured vast numbers
of buildings and infrastructure
destroyed a frantic rescue effort is
underway with courageous First
Responders combing through Rubble to try
and find those buried in debris and dust
the labor party along with the whole
house sends our deepest condolences
thoughts and sympathies to all those
whose lives have been devastated by this
tragedy
it struck at night when families were
sleeping it struck in winter with biting
winter temperatures and ice and snow
hampering relief
and it struck a part of the world that
has already known great tragedy and
suffering in recent years
but only have thousands of lives been
lost but it's caused anxiety for all the
people of Syria and turkey with towns
cut off as roads have been split in half
the people of Syria have faced a decade
of conflict and violence and they're
simply not the infrastructure to cope
with the Fallout of This Disaster turkey
of course is a close Ally of the United
Kingdom and there are many close ties of
family and friendship between Britain
and the people of Syria my own
constituency is home to a thriving
Turkish Kurdish and Syrian Community
there are an estimated 500 000 people of
Turkish origin living in the United
Kingdom I know the pain and anxiety that
they're now feeling they will want to
know that we have in place
all that we can do to support and help
them
when an international humanitarian
emergency arises like this Britain of
course must play its full part so can I
ask the foreign secretary to set out
what additional financial support we
will be that will be made available to
relief efforts in the region
and when those funds are likely to be
available can he also set out what
discussions he's had with International
organizations working on the ground to
ensure that that Aid is delivered and
whether the sanctions regime that we
have in place with Syria will hamper
some of that delivery uh he said of
course that he expects the number of
British Nationals sadly to rise does
this figure take into account the vast
numbers of dual Nationals that exist in
our country he explains what efforts are
being made by the scdo to ensure that
concerned Turkish and Syrian families in
the UK are kept informed will there be a
constituency hotline to support that
uh in December it was reported that the
S CEO Syria team had been instructed to
cut between six and eight million from
its overall budget can the foreign
secretary confirm whether he intends to
pursue this cut in the face of this
disaster and can he update the house
about not only the immediate response
which we're grateful for today but come
back with a long-term plan
or a secretary
uh Mr Speaker I think uh the uh I think
the most honorable gentleman for the
time that he's taken the points that he
has made and he is absolutely right that
he reflects I think the mood of the
whole house uh when we pass on our
thoughts not just to those in the
affected region but for those uh people
here in the UK and further afield who
may have friends family and loved ones
who have been affected by this uh
terrible situation with regard to
financial support as I say we have
already
given an uplift to the Syrian Civil
Defense the white helmet what other
assistance will be needed we will assess
in close coordination as say with the
United Nations and other non-government
delivery Partners on the ground
with uh with regards to the sanctions to
Syria uh the response in this area as I
said is predominantly going to be led by
the Turkish government in the areas that
they have control over and through
non-government agencies both uh Syrian
non-government agencies and
international agencies so and I will
check that this is the case my
estimations at the moment is that our
ability to support will not be hampered
by our sanctions regime when it comes to
the Future allocation or funds for Syria
and further Oda allocations we are
working through that process as we do
each year I'm not able to give him a uh
a complete answer to that at the moment
but of course we will look at all
allocations in
um in response to what we are sadly
seeing unfold on the ground and I will
of course the house updated show the
select committee unless you can my heart
goes out to
us loved ones who are still searching
for their loved ones and those British
Nationals affected the people of Syria
have lived through 12 years of
bombardment chemical weapons Barrel
bombs and rape but how does Assad who
has already decimated Healthcare
Services by double tapping a bombing and
respond yesterday afternoon he bombed
mare which was an ERA that was affected
by the earthquake in what was a truly
callous and heinous attack in
opportunism for him to try and continue
to attack and destroy the moderate
opposition
this is truly heinous and it was
something I warned the minister about
yesterday afternoon so can the foreign
secretary please confirm to me what we
are doing and what repercussions there
will be for Assad for these appalling
acts secondly how we will shame Russia
and China and to reopening the
humanitarian Corridor that has now been
closed for two years and finally when we
look at the integrated review refresh
where Syria has been noticeably absent
as we tilt towards the india-pacific
will he look at the fact that this has
turned into a narco State because we
have not kept our eyes on it because
those drugs are making their way to
Europe whether we like it or not
for a secretary uh Mr Speaker my
honorable friend is absolutely right
to highlight the uh completely
unacceptable uh bombing of areas in the
immediate aftermath of this natural
disaster sadly it speaks to a
long-standing pattern of behavior by the
Assad regime a regime that we condemn
have sanctioned and we will continue to
um
to bring it to to bring about uh
sanctions working with our International
friends and partners to try and prevent
Behavior like this from occurring again
sadly she will know the house will know
uh that
um Assad's Behavior and the behavior of
the Syrian government in this as in so
many other areas is completely
unacceptable I can assure her we have
not lost interest in this and the
situation in Syria and the response of
the Assad regime is a topic conversation
that regularly comes up when I speak to
interlocutors in the region and Beyond
the same piece of books burst and Chris
law
thank you Mr Speaker and the earthquakes
that hit turkey and Syria yesterday are
truly devastating and have been in all
our screens and I've just been here from
Sky News at least 5 000 have been
confirmed have been killed with this
death toll undoubtedly rise in the
common days and of course our thoughts
prayers and sympathies are all those
affected
footage shows a cute and widespread
destruction across Central and
Southeastern turkey and in Syria a
country's still suffering from over a
decade of war the cost of human life and
infrastructure is unthinkable
reports of emerged with survivors
calling out the rescue teams texting
loved ones and sending voice notes to
journalists for help many of whom cannot
be saved due to lack of rescue equipment
this is truly truly tragic
an SMP welcome scdl's decision to send a
team of search and rescue Specialists
equipment and rescue dogs to Turkey and
for coordination with the UN and support
for those in Syria the International
Community must continue listening to
those on the ground the U.N red crescent
and the white helmets in the coming days
and weeks so that the best relief and
assistance possible can be delivered
a main barrier will be accessed to Syria
in the first place with only one land
border between turkey and Syria so
therefore I ask what's the UK government
doing at the UN level to try and open
additional Crossing points for
humanitarian assistance
additionally getting Aid in humanitarian
relief across front lines and rebel-held
areas who require humanitarian Corridor
so can the minister detail what
negotiations are taking place to agree
this for affected communities and
furthermore turkey and Syria are in the
middle of a brutal code snap with many
roads and cities already covered in snow
and no damage in a disaster so is the
SCD organizing food supplies for the
medical Aid and in particularly called
weather equipment for survivors to
affected communities and finally Mr
Speaker given thousands have been left
homeless and have lost everything is the
UK government considering short-term
family scheme visas for those survivors
with families here in the UK to support
them
we're in sexual tray uh Mr Speaker I uh
thank the honorable gentleman for the
point he made about the speed of our
technical response
um the Utah team the urban search and
rescue team that we have uh dispatched
uh our world-class and they have
world-class equipment with regards to
the humanitarian access routes as I say
I'll be speaking to Martin Griffiths at
the UN later on this afternoon I know um
both at ministerial level and official
level we will be liaising with our
International Partners to make sure we
coordinate in terms of what turkey needs
for the uh the response
as I say I have uh already authorized
the deployment of a medical assessment
team the further stages of requirement
the requirement will evolve over time we
will of course work closely with our
International Partners to make sure we
address that
uh with regard to Syria as he says
working through organizations like the
red crescent un will be the way that we
deploy support there and with regard to
what more we can do to those dislocated
people of course we will coordinate with
the Turkish authorities with the Syrian
uh with those active in Syria as best we
can and will make any decisions in due
course
yesterday I was able to contact my
opposite number in the Turkish
delegation to the Council of Europe he
described the situation in Turkey as
overwhelming and he has now written to
us to thank us for all that we have done
does my honorable friend agree that we
should do as much as possible to help
the Turks in this terrible situation
uh my old friend makes an incredibly
important point this is the scale of
this catastrophe is one that we are
unused to and sadly for the for the very
reasons that have been mentioned uh both
the fact that this is a part of turkey
and Syria and particularly in Syria
which has been receiving end of a huge
amount of uh violence already and
because of the time of year and because
we are now seeing multiple shocks and
it's entirely feasible there may be more
this is a this is almost an
unprecedented situation we will of
course work very very closely with our
Turkish friends and allies in terms of
the ongoing assessment of need and our
response to that need working closely
with our International partners clock
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker the
human toll of this did not disaster is
immense and and I want to thank the
Secretary of State for the really Speedy
dispatch of British search and rescue
and Medical Teams like many British
Kurdish Turkish members of uh Community
my family woke up yesterday trying to
make sure to find out whether our deaths
and relatives our relatives were safe in
Turkey in Malaysia we were very lucky
that majority of our family are safe I
spent the whole day with um with Turkish
Kurdish and members of the community the
local community center hundreds of
people who were desperately trying to
find out if their loved ones are safe
the the foreign office has provided a
number helpline both it's only for
British citizens who were stuck in this
disaster there are thousands of
thousands of British people who have
been impacted by this can the Secretary
of State tell me what support if any
will be available to British members
British members British good people who
have family
um in Turkey who they're trying to find
news about what can he do
yeah
The Honorable lady makes an important
point about how disconcerting this is
for people who have friends and loved
ones in the region obviously the
responsibility of the fcdo is to provide
support for British Nationals overseas
that has to be our area of priority if
if there are people whether they be in
the UK or in the region or Beyond who
are fearful of British Nationals who may
be caught up for this then Our advice is
to get in contact with the fcbo she says
there is a there is a helpline that's or
there is a team that's been set up to
respond whilst I appreciate how
disconcerting it is obviously we we
don't have the capacity
um to to extend that level of support to
non-british Nationals but of course we
are working very closely with the
Turkish authorities and for those
organizations on the ground in Syria to
try and provide the maximum level of
support that we can for those
non-british Nationals who sadly have
been caught up in this terrible
situation not preacher thank you Mr
Speaker can I commend the foreign
secretary for his Speedy response to
those of his ministers and officials at
this time
um he will know that this tragedy is
still unfolding uh there have been great
stories of courage and survival
but does he agree that there's also been
an opportunity for international
cooperation and diplomacy from perhaps
unexpected sources such as the
government of Greece who sent 21
firefighters and other humanitarian and
rescue workers and the government of
Armenia and this is the time for the
region to come together in the common
effort of saving their fellow human
beings
foreign
friend makes an incredibly important
points and what we are what we are
seeing is a uh over and over again real
acts of solidarity
uh with the people of turkey and indeed
the people of Syria who have suffered uh
so much in uh as a result of these
earthquakes I'm uh I have no doubt
that there will be a number of terrible
stories uh unfolding through this awful
awful situation but also I think this is
an incredible opportunity for us to
demonstrate our shared humanity and our
desire to
um to maximize the effort
to prevent further loss of life and I
commend those countries in the region
who have put aside
um uh whatever difficulties they may
have to come together and support the
turkey and Syria in their time of need
Alice McGovern thank you Mr Speaker it's
hard to imagine a worse place in the
world for this to have happened and
gaziantep is only about 100 kilometers
from Aleppo in Syria and I know that the
foreign secretary and all ministers like
us on this side will be thinking of
those refugees who fled the horrors of
Aleppo and adlib only to be faced with
such a horrendous National disaster so
can I ask the foreign secretary just to
think again about the white helmet
specifically I wholeheartedly welcome
what he has said but that brave
organization has really struggled to
maintain its sustainability and I would
implore him as I and I know he will be
sympathetic to this to look again at
funding for them and make sure that we
do all we can to help the white helmets
Yeah
so Mr Speaker I'd like to take this
opportunity to commend The Honorable
lady for her long-standing commitment uh
to uh this part of the world and the
refugees from that part of the world
um we have been a long-standing
supporter of the of the white helmets as
she will know uh as I say we have given
a financial uplift in direct response to
this and we will of course look at what
the the longer term implications of
these earthquakes will be as we assess
what our international support will be
in the future I cannot give her a hard
commitment at this point I think she'll
understand that but we will of course
look very very seriously about the
implications of this terrible situation
thank you for thank you the situation is
truly horrific and it's good to know
that the UK is contributing not just at
Manpower but also expertise but we know
that without further help thousands more
people will die I see that an appeal has
been launched this morning by Oxfam The
Shred cross question Aid Islamic relief
action Aid uh will he join me in
encouraging Jewish people to dig deep
into their own Pockets because every
single pound will make a difference
foreign
is absolutely right there is a
long-standing tradition of uh generosity
and uh and I have no doubt that the
British people uh will of course provide
a huge amount of philanthropic uh
support to those affected
um as I say the UK government has
already made a commitment to
um to give funding and direct support to
the people in the relief effort and our
teams of uh experts will be a force
multiplier working as I say with
state-of-the-art equipment and
techniques some of the best Urban search
and rescue teams in the world and we
will of course have an ongoing
assessment of what further need turkey
and Syria have
thank you speaker may I thank the
Secretary of State for coming to the
house so that we can express our sorrow
and solidarity with the people of turkey
and Syria but also those families up and
down this country who are desperately
worried for those back home I welcome of
course the support that's been offered
in the offer potentially of more but may
I press him particularly on Syria
we know that organizations on the ground
are ill-equipped to hand out the support
that is desperately needed many of them
are also affected by these earthquakes
and he himself said this was exceptional
one in 80 years so while we aren't
planning to be sending personnel and
Equipment into Syria itself may I simply
urge him to think as creatively as he
can to make whatever exceptions he can
so that we can not hurt those who have
already been hurt so much
secretary thank you Mr Speaker is my
right will defend the development
Minister said earlier this morning we
are working closely with the United
Nations and we will look creatively at
what we can do to support them and our
partners on the ground to maximize our
ability to get humanitarian Aid and
support to the people who need it most
in Duncan Smith
Mr Speaker can I commend my run for
coming so swiftly to the house and for
the actions that he and the department
has already taken this is would have
been bad enough and a terrible enough
set of circumstances
in its own but to be overlaid by a
brutal civil war going on in the same
area and by a very very terrible winter
it makes it even worse Beyond almost
imagination I like many other in this
house have many Turkish and Turkish
cypriot constituents who are very very
worried now at this time about their
families and are finding it very
difficult to get proper information I
know my right old friend has put up a
hotline can I suggest to him it might
also be helpful because they're
contacting me and I'm sure they're
contacting my colleagues across the
house could we not have an MPS hotline
on this one specific so that we can help
our constituents to find out as much
information as possible and set their
their worries at ease
my rightful friend makes uh makes an
important point we will of course look
at the most effective way of providing
information one of the learnings we've
had from past uh Consular uh uh
challenges or acute situations like this
it's having one point of convergence is
often most effective I'm not going to be
high bound though and I will look at the
best way of making sure that whether
people whether people here in the UK are
trying to get information about British
Nationals or whether people of Turkish
or in deuterian Heritage are trying to
get information about non-british
Nationals we will look to facilitate
that obviously for non-british Nationals
we don't hold uh necessarily the
information and I'll look very carefully
about what he says about ensuring that
parliamentary colleagues have Swift and
accurate access to information I'll
update the house on that and duplicate
it thank you Mr Speaker I thank the
minister for his statement and and
please let me express my condolences for
all those and who have lost their loved
ones and my thoughts especially are to
my large Turkish diaspora who call
Edmonton their home I would like to ask
the minister that he would commit to
giving regular the updates in the house
for those who are worried and also would
he be able to give us an update on what
additional Aid will be provided once
this initial assessment has been done
well it's actually The Honorable lady
makes a a sad but important point
that this situation will evolve and
sadly I think is highly likely to get
much worse before it gets better I will
of course make sure that my office
liaises with Mr Speaker about the most
effective way to provide timely updates
to the house whether it be via the
dispatch box or in some other format I
recognize I recognize that certainly
over the next few days and going into
next week perhaps when the house isn't
sitting the dispatch mocks might not be
the most effective way of doing so but I
also recognize that that this this
situation will be coming to perhaps its
peak over the next couple of days and
and rightly members of this house will
expect to have updates and I will I will
try and find some way of most
effectively facilitating that so Julian
thank you Mr Speaker a situation of this
sort in a fellow NATO member would seem
to be tailor made for military
assistance from us to their civil powers
do we not have any Royal Navy ships in
the area and are there not Royal Marine
contingents that could be put quickly to
work with the agreement of the Turkish
authorities
very secretary Speaker of course I will
take the the ideas that the right
honorable gentleman put forward very
very seriously certainly the initial
assessment of need is very much in the
urban search and rescue and the UK along
with a number of other NATO and non-nato
uh partners are putting forward that
capability I suspect medical
assistance will be next but we will
continue liasing very very closely with
the Turkish government and the United
Nations about what is needed on each
side of the Border
thank you Mr Speaker and my heart goes
out to all of those people who have
suffered in this and continue to suffer
in this Dreadful earthquake the loss of
humanitarian Aid routes to Northwest
Syria which went down from four to one
in 2020 has had an immeasurable impact
on the effective delivery of Aid to the
area this has meant virtually no
resources and help for those already
worsening in the this Dreadful
humanitarian situation that was already
there let alone
coping with the impacts of This truly
awful earthquake so how is the Secretary
of State going to ensure that Aid is
going to get to the people who need it
Mr Speaker the uh The Honorable lady
raises a a very important point a point
that I raised in my last bilateral
meeting with Martin Griffiths it is
something which has as she said had a
significant detrimental effect on the
international community's ability to
provide humanitarian support to some
of the most uh needy people in the world
particularly now in the time of winter
and particularly in light of these
earthquakes I can assure her and the
house that I when I speak with Martin
Griffiths later on today this is exactly
one of the topics that we'll be
discussing
you uh Mr Speaker it's a stark reminder
of the importance of resilience our
ability to deal with these acute events
whether they happen to us or our ability
to help others could I very much welcome
the statement from the foreign secretary
but the first 72 hours as he knows are
absolutely critical military assistance
has been mentioned we have Assets in
Cyprus including rotary systems that
could be put to use I'm wondering
whether we could offer these to the
Turkish authorities in this critical
time period
uh Mr Speaker we have uh been in close
contact as I say very early in this
situation uh with our Turkish
counterparts uh obviously we have
um a very close military uh relationship
through NATO uh turkey are a large and
sophisticated armed forces in their own
right the thing they have asked us for
most is one of the areas where we
genuinely provide
world-class uh top of the class
capability and that's in our Urban
search and rescue teams of course as the
situation evolves and sadly as I say
it's a high likelihood it will
deteriorate we will listen very very
carefully to what further requirements
they have when we respond in due course
okay so thank you Mr sweetheart in just
a matter of weeks the holy months of
Ramadan were Muslims pass from down to
dusk begins yet Muslims and others in
Syria and turkey are in the middle of
harsh weather conditions with many roads
and cities covered in snow and now
damaged by less disaster so does the
fcdo plan to work with International
Partners to organize and I'm
specifically asking the hygiene products
including Sanitary products is we know
that natural disasters
disproportionately impact women in girls
and while the foreign secretary join me
in commending Charities such as Islamic
relief who have mobilized teams in both
Syria and atarchy and since Monday have
already raised over 1 million pounds to
help those affected
Mr Speaker I'm I'm happy to pay tributes
to Islamic relief and uh other
organizations other Charities
non-governmental organizations that are
active in the region she is absolutely
right that sadly whether it be natural
disaster or conflict or man-made
disaster women and girls always bear the
brunt it is one of the sad truisms of uh
development and humanitarian relief so
she is absolutely right to raise the
specific needs of women and girls I'm
very proud to say that through my whole
time as a minister and a Secretary of
State uh the plight of women and girls
has been at the heart of our foreign
policy and development policy and we
will seek to ensure whether it's
directly or through partners that we we
put forward plans to specifically
address the needs of women and girls in
this incredibly difficult set of
circumstances we missed the speaker I've
watched everyone across the UK has and
around the world with horror and
heartbreak at the scenes from the
earthquake in in Syria and turkey I know
that whenever a disaster happens the UK
always steps up and people are so
generous with wanting to help and I ask
my right honorable friend if he could
just confirm what steps people could do
in Watford and across the UK to donate
and to help other people so that reaches
the front line and helps those who are
currently suffering the imaginable
unimaginable very secretary uh Mr
Speaker I have no doubt that a um a
number of organizations uh will in fact
I know a number of organizations we've
already discussed Islamic relief Red
Cross red crescent there'll be a number
of organizations that will be putting
forward appeals of course we recognize
that uh for many many people in the UK
the economic situation is difficult but
I have no doubt notwithstanding those
domestic circumstances chances the
British people will do what they always
do which is rise to the occasion and
support people around the world who are
even in even greater need than they are
Jessica Morton thank you very much Mr
Speaker I'm following on from The
Honorable my own book from Field North
and others members of the Kurdish
Turkish community in Newport are clearly
also desperately worried about family
members and friends and our hearts go
out to them can I just reiterate to the
Secretary of State what others have said
the need for really clear channels of
communication to help us make
urgent inquiries of cons for
constituents whether it be drop-ins
upstairs or or whatever really and
support in country for UK citizens and
dual Nationals as well as us doing
everything we can on a humanitarian
level for a second I completely
recognize the um the desire of the house
to be kept informed and also to be able
to provide a service to the constituents
who quite understandably will be very
very worried about your friends loved
ones I will tell you that on board my uh
my team will be making notes of what she
and the other members of the House have
said on this thank you Mr Speaker and
having spend a considerable amount of
time in Turkey during my lifetime can I
share the comments that the foreign
secretary had said and say how much I
agree with them can I also Echo the
calls that we need to ensure that the
white helmets continue to receive
funding in the long term I met with them
in October last year and they said it
was absolutely key to see British
funding continue to continue the good
work that they're doing just in relation
to his statement can I ask how many
people he is intending to deploy from
the medical assessment team and can I
also just commend all of the volunteers
that have gone from our rapid response
unit within the foreign office to help
in turkey at such short notice and just
following on from the member for
watford's point about making sure we are
signposting where the British public can
give money and Aid to people in turkey
and how we can go about that and lastly
Mr Speaker can we ensure that the
reporting mechanisms coming out of
turkey are giving him real time to
members of parliament so that we might
be able to respond in helping
constituents find out about loved ones
but also how we can most effectively
help
foreign secretary with regard to his
specific question about the size of the
Medical Response Team I don't have that
figure at the moment the point I would
make to the house is it is inevitable uh
that the the numbers both in terms of
the sadly the fatalities the injuries
and also the numbers of British experts
that we put into support will will
change over time and indeed I strongly
suspect that the figures that I outlined
at the scratch box at the start of the
statement are now sadly already out of
date I completely take the point that he
and others have made about the need for
accurate and ongoing And Timely
information and I will endeavor to make
sure that I provide that to all members
of the House pin jobs thank you Mr
Speaker I'd like to send my thoughts and
condolences to all those who have
suffered and lost loved ones and the
tragedy in Syria and turkey this
horrific disaster does not discriminate
in its victims and political obstacles
must not be allowed to Define who
receives our support So can the
Secretary of State explain what he's
doing to secure humanitarian corridors
to ensure all syrians receive
humanitarian Aid and will he respond to
appeals for more heavy lifting equipment
and fuel to run those machines
for a secretary The Honorable lady is
absolutely right that disasters like
this do not discriminate and neither we
will we we will work closely with the
United Nations obviously we do not have
a relationship with the Assad government
in Syria but notwithstanding that we
will work with those organizations
whether it be the white helmets the
United Nations or others who are on the
ground in Syria and of course work
closely with the Turkish government in
uh in response to that
holiday thank you Mr Speaker my thoughts
with my constituents who are so
desperately worried about loved ones and
I Echo the comments made by members
across the house of the need for that
timely and accurate information to help
Syrian Kurdish and Turkish Nationals
living in the UK who've been affected by
this but I wonder if the acceptors take
an answer what representations the UK is
making to drive up humanitarian access
to Syria from Turkey up the
international agenda and open new flows
of Aid to Northwest Syria
uh Mr Speaker this is a a specific
subject that I'll be writing with Martin
Griffiths when I speak to him later on
this afternoon humanitarian access
routes have been constrained over recent
years that has caused more suffering and
it's something that we will seek to
address
thank you very much Mr Speaker given the
immense scale of this terrible tragedy
and the report this morning that people
are using their mobile phones while
trapped under the rubble as they cry for
help do we have the capacity to send a
further search and rescue team because
it would I think seem given the scale
that that would certainly assist and
secondly may ask him does he expect the
disaster's emergency committee to issue
an appeal
um I will on his last point I will uh
certainly look at that and I'll ask my
officials to liaise with regard to
raising a specific appeal
um whatever what future assistance we
give I think will be very much Guided by
the requests of the Turkish authorities
and the feedback of the initial wave of
experts that we have uh provided
um I realized I failed to fully answer
uh The Honorable ladies question about
heavy lift equipment and fuel thereof
again that will be something that we
will listen very carefully to the
request from the Turkish authorities one
of the reasons why actually our USA team
is so valuable is because we we have got
absolutely state of the art search and
rescue equipment which coordinates very
very closely with the uh the other
equipment that is easier to get onto the
ground by those Partners who are
physically closer to the incident
each other speaker the trial sector has
been really helpful this morning and our
French
everyone's being paid we're not experts
but when I see these pictures on the
television uh and hear voices calling
children calling for help the the crisis
is now can we get people heavy lifting
equipment the right expertise they're
now in Planes getting there now to
rescue these local children they're
families we're in Secretary
I miss uh Mr Speaker the The Honorable
gentleman's a desire to help and help
quickly is completely understandable I
can assure him is shared by everyone
right across the house and right across
uh government I spoke as I say I um I
had an exchange of uh Communications
with my uh Turkish counterpart first
thing uh yesterday uh morning
our Urban search and rescue team were
mobilized uh convened uh yesterday and
they will be on the ground and
operational
um uh the assessment is by uh by today
this is a very Swift response
um and I recognize however that this is
a challenge that is going to be enduring
and of course that feedback from them in
terms of what else that we can do and do
quickly will be incredibly important
we'll do that in close coordination uh
with our International friends and
partners Chris Stevens thank you and Mr
Speaker and can I thank the foreign
statement This Disaster has been keenly
felt by the goddess Community across
these islands and foreign
charities in the College Community I'm
thinking for example the cobblies red
crescent charity and to make sure that
the cottage population get this support
the needs and that they aid goes to help
the college people we're here
the speaker is right the people of this
region have suffered more than enough
and sadly this natural disaster will
amplify the suffering uh of the man-made
disaster that we have seen in that uh
part of Syria and the ripple effect that
that has had into that part of turkey I
can assure him that we will work with as
wide a range of international Partners
as possible to ensure that no Community
is in any way disadvantaged in terms of
our supporters and say this
um as The Honorable lady said that this
tragedy has not discriminated and
neither will we
condolences by the foreign secretary the
number of those who have died and have
been injured is immeasurable
and send my condolences to to everyone
in in that area scammers may use social
media information to con contact
individuals in the UK with links to
their impacted regions using the feels
for loved ones to request money
transfers what measures of the UK
government considering to ensure that
such scams are highlighted and families
are protected
the speaker sadly the honorable lady
makes an incredibly important point
there will always be vultures that will
seek to make money through the tragedy
and of others and the concern of their
friends and loved ones my strong advice
is the same as we had as we were given
in all circumstances be very very
suspicious of unsolicited Communications
far better to go to well-established
Avenues of support they often in
circumstances like this the most
effective on the ground anyway and urge
people to
not let their understandable desire to
give support quickly blind them to the
fact that there are people that will
seek to take advantage of their good
work she's absolutely right to raise it
Mr Speaker can I also thank the minister
very much for his positive answers and
and for the very obvious as well
government compassion for those who have
suffered much due to the earthquake and
uh on my uh um thoughts as well for all
those and prayers for all those who have
lost loved ones the earthquake has
affected large areas of Northern Syria
including the Kurdish region where Manya
cities are still attempting to recover
after the death genocide will UK Aid
Center relieve the suffering caused by
the earthquake also be sent to minority
communities rather than just to the
large population centers they all need
help thank you
uh Mr Speaker the uh honorable gentleman
who speaks regularly and with great
Passion about the need to particularly
be conscious of minority groups
particularly religious and ethnic
minority groups he's absolutely right to
do so I can give him the assurance that
I will in turn seek assurances from my
officials that our support is reaching
everyone that it needs to and not just
those who uh perhaps have the best
pre-established roots for a humanitarian
support